This lecture is about the text
representation.
In this lecture we're going to discuss
text representation.
And discuss how natural language
processing can allow us to represent
text in many different ways.
Let's take a look at this example
sentence again.
We can represent this sentence in many
different ways.
1st.
We can always represent such a
sentence as a string of characters.
This is true for all the languages when
we store them in the computer.
When we store a natural language
sentence as a string of characters,
we have perhaps the most general way of
representing text, since we can always use
this approach to represent any text
data.
But unfortunately, using such a
representation would not help us do
semantic analysis, which is often
needed for many applications of text
mining.
The reason is because we're not even
recognizing words.
So as a string we're going to keep all
the spaces and these ASCII symbols.
We can perhaps count how... what's the
most frequent character in English
text, or the correlation between those
characters, but we can't really analyze
semantics.
Yet this is the most general way of
representing text, because we can use
this to represent any natural language
text.
If we try to do a little bit more
natural language processing by doing
word segmentation.
Then we can obtain a representation of
the same text, but in the form of a
sequence of words.
So here we see that we can identify
words like: a, dog, is, chasing, etc.
Now with this level of representation,
we certainly can do a lot of things,
and this is mainly because words are
the basic units of human communication
in natural language, so they are very
powerful.
By identifying words we can, for
example, easily count what are the most
frequent words in this document or in
the whole collection, etc.
And these words can be used to form
topics.
When we combine related words together
and some words are positive, some words are
negative, so we can also do sentiment
analysis.
So representing text data as a sequence of
words opens up a lot of interesting
analysis possibilities.
However, this level of representation
is slightly less general than string of
characters, because in some languages
such as Chinese,
it's actually not that easy to
identify all the word boundaries,
because in such a language you see text
as a sequence of characters with no
space in between.
So you have to rely on some special
techniques to identify words.
In such a language, of course, then we
might make mistakes in segmenting
words.
So the sequence of words representation
is not as robust as string of
characters.
But in English it's very easy to obtain
this level of representation, so we can
do that all the time.
Now if we go further to do natural
language processing, we can add a part
of speech tags.
Now, once we do that, we can count for
example, the most frequent nouns or
what kind of nouns are associated with
what kind of verbs, etc.
So this opens up a little bit more
interesting opportunities for further
analysis.
Note that I use the plus sign here,
because by representing text as a
sequence of part of speech tags.
We don't necessarily replace the
original word sequence representation
Instead, we add this as an additional
way of representing text data, so that
now the data is represented as both a
sequence of words, and a sequence of
part of speech tags.
This enriches the representation of text
data and thus, also,
enables a more interesting
analysis.
If we go further then we'll be parsing
the sentence to obtain a
syntactic structure.
Now this of course further open up
more interesting analysis of, for
example, the writing styles,
or correcting grammar mistakes.
If we could go further for
semantic analysis, then we might be
able to recognize dog as animal and we
also can recognize boy as a person
and playground as a location.
And we can further analyze their
relations,
for example, dog is chasing the boy and
the boy is on the playground.
Now this is to add more entities and
relations through entity-relation
recognition.
At this level, then we can do even more
interesting things.
For example, now we can count easily
the most frequent person that's
mentioned in this whole collection of
news articles, or whenever you mention
this person, you also tend to see
mention of another person, etc.
So this is very useful representation
an it's also related to the Knowledge
Graph that some of you may have heard
of.
That Google is doing as a more semantic
way of representing text data.
However, it's also less robust than
sequence of words or even syntactic
analysis, because it's not always easy to
identify all the entities with the
right types, and we might make
mistakes, and relations are even harder
to find and we might make mistakes.
So this makes this level of
representation less robust, yet it's
very useful.
Now if we move further to logical
representation then we can have predicates and
even inference rules. And with inference rules we can infer interesting, derived facts from the text. So that's very useful, but unfortunately at this level of representation it's even less robust and we can make mistakes,
and we can't do that all the time for
all kinds of sentences.
And finally, speech acts with added yet
another level of representation of the
intent of saying this sentence.
So in this case it might be a request.
So knowing that would allow us to
analyze more, even more interesting
things about the observer order.
Author of this sentence, what's the
intention of saying that?
What scenarios, what kind of actions
will be made?
So this is...
Another level of analysis that would be
very interesting.
So this picture shows that if we move
down, we generally see more
sophisticated natural language
processing techniques to be used.
And unfortunately, such techniques
would require more human effort.
And they are less accurate.
That means there are mistakes.
So if we analyze text data at the
levels that are represented, deeper
analysis of language, then we have to
tolerate the errors.
So that also means it's still necessary
to combine such deep analysis with
shallow analysis based on, for example
sequence of words. On the right side you
see the arrow points down,
to indicate that as we go down with our
representation of text, it's closer to
knowledge representation in our mind,
and need for solving a lot of problems.
Now, this is desirable because as we
can represent text at the level of
knowledge, we can easily extract the
knowledge.
That's the purpose of text mining.
So there is a trade off here between
doing deeper analysis that might have
errors, but would give us direct
knowledge that can be extracted from
text and doing shallow analysis, which
is more robust.
But wouldn't actually give us the
necessary deeper representation of
knowledge. I should also say that text
data are generated by humans
and are meant to be consumed by humans,
so as a result in a text data analysis
text mining, humans play a very
important role.
They are always in the loop.
Meaning that we should optimize the
collaboration of humans and computers.
So in that sense, it's OK that
computers may not be able to have
completely accurate representation of
text data and patterns that are
extracted from text data can be
interpreted by humans, and humans can
guide the computers to do more accurate
analysis by annotating more data by
providing features to guide the machine
learning programs to make them work
more effectively.